paul tudor jones went on cnbc this
morning they cleared out the schedule
for paul tudor jones pcj comes to town
everyone off the set one-on-one
interview with a little bit of remote
help he had a bunch to say and frankly i
think that paul tudor jones is one of
the clearest thinkers when it comes to
macroeconomics right now and what you as
an investor can be doing with your
portfolio he had four specific talking
points the first is that inflation is
worse and will be worse than most people
anticipate the second is that the
greatest threat to markets in society
right now is inflation the third was
that the most appropriate the most
inappropriate monetary policy in his
lifetime is occurring right now and the
fourth is that bitcoin is his preferred
hedge to inflation well above gold so
we've got quotes from him here the first
quote says quote i think to me the
number one issue facing main street
investors is inflation and it's pretty
clear to me that inflation is not
transitory directly going against what
the mainstream narrative it's probably
the single biggest threat to certainly
financial markets and i think to society
just in general paul tudor jones one of
the best investors in the world coming
out and saying the truth which is all
this nonsense about inflation being
transitory is nonsense it is not true
we've had persistent multi-month 5 plus
percent cpi inflation absolutely bonkers
but it's not just a concern in an
academic sense it hurts people there is
45 of our society that holds zero
dollars in investable assets inflation
is eating away at their wealth it is
stealing their purchasing power it is
making every single item in their life
go up in terms of cost and rich people
who hold assets are benefiting from this
so literally you have the rich people
cheering it on because they're getting
richer and richer and richer bitcoin's
going up everyone's celebrating stocks
are going up everyone's celebrating but
those who hold no investments are
getting punished the key to this don't
complain you will not change it i will
not change it nobody will exchange it
educate yourself and learn what are the
rich people doing so that i can protect
myself so that i can benefit just like
they can you have the opportunity go
ahead and get invested doesn't matter
what asset go get invested the second
quote we have from paul tudor jones says
inflation can be much worse than what we
fear we have the demand side of the
equation and that is 3.5 trillion
dollars greater than what it normally
would have been just sitting in liquid
deposits they can go into stocks or
crypto or real estate or be consumed so
that's a huge amount of dry powder just
sitting waiting to be utilized at some
point which is why inflation is not
going away the people who have been
telling you that inflation is transitory
are either ignorant or stupid that is
the only reason why you believe
inflation is actually transitory when
you understand that they have printed
trillions of dollars and they're
stuffing it in every crevice of the
financial system we got the high levels
of inflation that they said was never
going to come and now you have paul
tudor jones saying inflation is not
going to go away they definitely are not
going to take the prices down on an
aggregate basis and he believes that we
will continue to have a high rate of
change uh an increase in inflation
moving forward and then lastly he said
it's absolutely dead for a 60 40
portfolio for a long stock long bond
portfolio so the real question is how
you defend yourselves against it paul
tudor jones the legend of wall street
calling for the death of the 60 40
portfolio if you're sitting in a 60 40
portfolio right now 40 of your portfolio
is losing money that's how bad it is and
so obviously when you have one of the
best traders in history talking about
this people start to pay attention
now he was asked specifically about
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies and he had
to say that bitcoin and crypto is
obviously winning it has been a great
trade he still has single digit
percentages of his portfolio allocated
to the space but that bitcoin is his
preferred inflation hedge over gold
again we talked about over the last 12
months on a nominal basis gold is down 7
on a real rate basis it is down over 12
gold is dead we can have a funeral for
it drop gold you literally held gold and
you lost instead bitcoin up 400 plus
percent paul tudor jones looked like an
absolute genius when he was on
television last year telling everyone i
have to move into inflation hedge assets
and i believe that bitcoin will be the
fastest horse how accurate and on top of
this has paul tudor jones been oh he's
definitely accurate but i i think about
it in two ways right so one is you're
right gold is dead you can look at it
from the past year two years five years
ten years whatever we have had uh really
really really bad inflation for the past
year along with the uh pandemic and all
this other stuff stimulus going on and
everything gold should have performed
well it didn't right it's an older asset
when it comes to inflation hedge and
there's obviously new assets like
bitcoin that have taken its place
secondly i think the biggest thing to
think about is we talk about this all
the time but the bottom percentage of
earners in this country get hurt the
worst with inflation right and everyone
knows this but the idea is that they
spend an inordinate amount of their
income a much higher percentage of their
income on the goods that are increasing
in price the most right rent food
electricity all this kind of stuff right
so the stuff that is increasing in price
the most they get hit with why the
people that are wealthy or rich off or
rich spend less of their money on this
stuff so i think the thing that flips
the light bulb for a lot of people who
are new to bitcoin specifically is to
look at it as a savings account right
it's just something that you're putting
your savings in so you have a certain
amount of cash that you can live on that
you need immediately to purchase uh food
in case of emergency stuff like that
right but then you move everything else
into bitcoin because it's sound money
it's
digitally scarce uh it has a constraint
or fixed supply right and you can
predict kind of the supply and demand
equation it's historically appreciated
in price right and it's something that
protects your purchasing power so i
think when you look at it more as a
savings account versus a speculative
investment that new people kind of come
in and they assume that's what people
are doing it starts to make a lot more
sense why the average investor and
average individual would care about it
john inflation isn't going anywhere i
don't know why they're saying it was
transitory to begin with they knew it
wasn't um now they're blaming supply
bottlenecks um inflation will continue
to rise i think on an absolute basis
maybe on a percent basis over the next
year it might not be five six percent
because it's already risen so much paul
twojone hit it right on the head um
bitcoin way better of an inflation hedge
than gold gold's up about eight percent
over the last 10 years
not looking good um people look for
eight percent returns on an annual basis
not a decade basis so
i uh i would put my money on bitcoin
appreciating more over the next 10 years
versus gold and that's exactly what i'm
doing look you're also just when you
just think about it in kind of the
easiest sense possible right you're
making a bet that the newest investors
in the world the millennials the the the
new generation right that's moving into
an investing class that's inheriting
money
building their own wealth and investing
in assets how many people do you know
that are 20 25 30 years old that are
buying gold i don't know a single one i
don't ain't nobody buying literally
cash is trash and gold issues so you're
literally just making a bet that the new
investors are going to adopt these
digital assets and if we know anything
it's literally that that they live on
the internet they want digital assets
and bitcoin is certainly a part of that
portfolio
when we think about paul tudor jones
saying this he completely removed career
risk for people on wall street if you go
back and you look at the sequence of
when he actually said hey i'm gonna
start allocating to this he started with
two percent he said he's gonna be the
fastest horse one he was right two he
started kind of the domino effect of
really reducing career risk or people on
wall street we then very quickly soon
after their head stanley druckenmiller
come out and a bunch of other folks
started to say hey paul tudor jones is
in i'm in as well one that's a testament
to paul tudor jones and how well
respected he is also two though was they
needed some heavyweight they needed a
legend to absolutely come in and not
only do it because they'd already
allocated but to say it to stake their
reputation put the flag in the ground
and say not only did i did it but i have
conviction enough to talk about it and
once one of the legends kind of did that
it was game on and it literally became
hunting season on wall street and every
single large hedge fund manager that's
got half a brain went and allocated to
this we got anthony scaramucci coming on
later they're buying hundreds of
millions of dollars worth of bitcoin
right if you had a large capital pool
and you didn't buy bitcoin your investor
should be asking you what the hell did
you miss this is up 400
and literally people were on television
and q3 last year saying like paul tudor
jones like stanley druckenmiller i'm
getting exposure to this because it's
going to be the fastest horse how do you
miss it's your job to get allocation if
you missed major major problems now if
you're a publicly traded company and
you're sitting there with a hundred
percent of uh your balance sheet in cash
and cash equivalents and you're not
thinking about allocating to this again
shareholders should be demanding an
answer why are you sitting with 100 of
your balance sheet in cash and cash
equivalents you know that there's five
percent inflation if it was one month of
five percent push you say hey we got
caught off guard didn't realize
inflation was going to be that bad two
months hey you know what we can't move
that quick three months hey sorry you
know we're working on four months okay
what are you doing let's go you're
letting our value of our balance sheet
be eroded away and you're not doing
anything about it even if you're holding
some sort of bond you're still losing
and so what i think we're gonna start to
see here is lps in these funds are gonna
start saying hey how the hell do we not
have exposure to this asset how is it
that literally there's millions of
people on the internet who have cat
photos and laser eyes and they don't
even use their real names and they front
ran you how is it that they beat you
right why should i be paying you fees
and you're not getting me exposure to
the best assets what am i doing i can
just go on one of these exchanges and
buy it myself if you're not gonna do
your job then on top of that you've got
publicly traded companies where uh
equity holders are going to start saying
itself wait a minute why are we sitting
here with in some cases tens of billions
of dollars in cash or in some cases
there's some companies had over 100
billion dollars in cash what are you
doing oh you decided you're gonna buy
gold from an inflation edge standpoint
cool you accelerated the destruction of
our shareholder value
we should fire you and fire you is we
probably can't remove you from running
the business but what we can do is we
can fire you from our portfolio we can
literally sell our shares and move it
somewhere that actually is going to be
better positioned and i think that's the
conversation that's coming and it's
going to piss off the mainstream media
it's going to piss off wall street but
again this asset is inevitable at this
point and if you do not have exposure
and you are a financial advisor or
you're an asset manager your client
should fire you if you are a shareholder
in a publicly traded company and they're
not putting this on their balance sheet
and they're sitting there taking five
plus percent persistent inflation on the
chin you should literally fire them from
your portfolio because what they are
doing is they are now intentionally they
are complicit in destroying shareholder
value they are letting the melting ice
cube melt there are options
in the market they can go allocate
billions of dollars into this asset and
protect their purchasing power but they
either haven't done the work or they've
done the work and they're wrong and if
they're bad at making that decision
actually protecting the shareholder
value on their balance sheet what other
decisions are they making that probably
are going to turn out poorly it just
shows bad decision-making and so my
guess is that if we fast-forward 6-12
months this is going to be the
conversation everyone's having that's
saying wait a minute we now have to have
and have not the haves are the people
who have half a brain and actually put
bitcoin in their portfolios or on their
balance sheets and the have-nots are
literally the people who are still
holding on to yesteryear and what's
going to happen is shareholders are
going to rise up and they're going to
start firing them from their portfolio
cool them off
get them done